here I mean in America we don't animals
get more rights because we don't need
them as much you know animals get extra
rights here
you know you might see two gay dogs
getting married here in New Hampshire or
in you know over in uh in Albuquerque
you might see a couple of gay Dobermans
out there you know doing sex and looking
for rich ring shopping
you know you might see a here in Beverly
Hills you'll see you know last year they
had a famous Bichon that a lady tried to
get a nose job for it for a Bichon just
because you know it wasn't you know it
wasn't appeasing some of the selfies and
stuff she was taken for her it wasn't
good enough you know and you'll see um
you know you'll see someone out here
with like uh you'll see like some of
them like a tender mannequin with like a
veal but like a baby goat that he
rescued or something now he's walking it
over there on Santa Monica Boulevard or
in West Hollywood but that's just
because you don't have nests you don't
have necessity for the animals here you
know you get up into Montana you get up
into Mississippi they got people they'll
they see a deer they're gonna gun it
down you know and but they're gonna eat
it they're not just you know it's not
just drive-by shooting animals you know
they use them the animals are of
necessity and when you get out there to
Africa you get out there to the big
black continent you know the big that
big mysterious that Mother Earth and
that thing is just the damn womb of the
world if you haven't been Africa and
looked into an African man's eyes all
right that's where they got the idea for
Lion King if you haven't look I've been
I think I'm in Africa maybe six seven
times and you look into a Kenyan man's
eyes you can see the beginning of
humanity and I know that might sound
wild to you but their eyes just go so
much deeper then then a lot of other
than a lot of the eyes here in America
because we got new eyes here you know
this country's only been around for so
long
you know but you get into though you get
into the depth into those you know
visual swimming pools
you know there's wading waters that are
sitting in a in a in an African man's
skull you can really and I'm serious
here you can see back into the almost
the beginning of time you know a lot of
people out there are looking in space
Elon Musk out there hunting around in
space how to travel through time well
I'll say this if you shoot you fire me
good and hard and concise and you
organized me enough and you shoot me
right into a into a into a real black
African man's eye sockets I bet you I
show up a million years in the past then
I'll be back there just bare just
bareback riding a damn Valarie oSIsoft
aesthetic us you know I'll be back there
I'll be back there on one of them snack
I dactyls you know and those are
beautiful animals that only snacks
imagine that no meals lunch dinner
breakfast brunch [ __ ] all that snack and
a coke eats when it wants to it doesn't
live by these codes a snack an echo eat
when it wants to other people sitting
down for dessert a snack adapt or break
out a bowl of [ __ ] cereal at 4:00
a.m. because that's how they behave but
back to my original thought now so in
some places they kill animals they need
them it's a necessity and when you get
to Africa okay when you get to that big
a you know where Indiana Jones went a
couple times looking for treasure when
you get there you see a couple
caterpillars go by that's like bison
okay that is moving lunch right there in
places where people are starving and
that's real stuff so you get over there
that's a real deal you know people like
you hear that in the middle of the night
do it like I think I hear something
and somebody look outside and it's just
a caterpillar but that don't mean
anything it means you get the spears out
cuz that's lunch you know that could be
dinner and I'll tell you this story I
was in Vietnam I might have told this
story before I have a very short term
long-term memory loss and I was in
Vietnam and you know you can go to the
markets there and they kill an animal
right there for you in the market you
know what I'm saying you wanna uh
you want an hour you want a little bit
of our meat chop chop
get and next thing you know they gotta
you know they got the owl right there
they got a you know I'm no birth
certificate they say no Cabbage Patch
[ __ ] cutleries Cutler replaced this
is the real deal they got an owl
you know chop chop you know they got a
um aardvark you want a little bit of
aardvark next thing you know they
cracked cracked open a spine of aardvark
you know and they got it you know they
pouring a marrow into a cup and they dip
in you out a couple of a couple of a
couple of arc medallions you know next
thing you know you rolling out of there
with eight little cuts of you know vark
so people you know you go into these
Vietnamese markets anything is a meat
what do you want you want a little bit I
mean they look dude it for some if some
bit some visitors went missing did I
guarantee you they show up on a menu in
a market you want two panels of Cathy
huh you want a couple grams uh Andy we
got him so I went in there and I was
thinking you know with these American
thoughts you know went in there like oh
they got a pit they had a couple of uh
pigeons in there you know or might have
been what is it um some of God's
Canaries you know a couple partridges
that a couple partridges in there in a
cage you could buy them you know dollar
a partridge so I'm thinking I'll get me
a partridge I'm gonna set it free I'm
gonna change the game you know I'm gonna
be this big you know fancy fella here
I'm gonna come in here and show these
vietze how to change the game by setting
animals free dude I bought one dollar
for uh Parkers right get that Partridge
I'll run outside I mean this is my
moment in the Sun you know this is my
this I'll let that that Partridge loose
man I tell you
immediately eight different Vietnamese
people jumped on this parkas they had a
one do pulled a sword out of his belt
and went right at the Parkers dude
another dude came rolling off of a tree
branch dropped down on a rope and try to
snatch for it another I mean people came
it was like it was choreographed by the
Lord
it was just not just eight different
levels of Partridge attackers and one
guy got to it first right grabbed it
right out there in the wild no open in a
in a parking lot by a Vietnamese market
snapped its neck did a nip neck snap on
that Partridge you know I'm not talking
l5 s1 did I'm talking he'll nine I'm
talking about an up top snapped its neck
and just put it right on his shoulder
because the Vietnamese have small little
shoulders you know barely could hold a
book on them barely could really hold a
small book or a notepad you kind of
probably comfortably set a notepad but
they got very very small shoulders and
he walked off and that's when I realized
wow yeah animal rights definitely but uh
but these people aren't killing these
partridges over here because for fun
that man was going home that man was
going to have Thanksgiving dinner or
whatever you know Vietnamese holiday
supported their a meal that man was
gonna feed his family so I guess if you
got a meal man get your meal you know I
know I'm gonna go over to Mississippi
this year for Christmas Eve I spend my
Christmas Eve in Mississippi and you
know that's somebody give me share
sharing up a rare meat over there you
know and I'll do it off dude I will I
will find a way to get a little bit of
dove or some venison or he'll if they
had vark I'd have a slice of that you
know I don't know what they'll have you
know turtle you know a little bit of
horse or something whatever it evening
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better what if
you watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches wall
ah